picture-perfect Scotland the highlands
famous for their breathtaking landscapes
the castles and lakes add some bagpipes
on a kilt and this is the way tourists
experience this part of Britain the
workers on the strawberry farms however
don't get to see this side of Scotland
almost all of them came here from
Eastern Europe they earn around 300
euros per week here
that equals a month's wage in Romania
and Bulgaria Dmitry Eon has been
spending the summer months in Scotland
for seven years now as an EU citizen he
never had problems entering the country
but brexit could mean the end of freedom
of movement my slides and if I pay rent
here during the summer some 10,000
workers from other EU countries are
employed in the Scottish agricultural
sector
brexit also has a whirring effect on
Scottish farmers the politicians in
London neglect and abandon us says Angus
Porter who runs the farm he employs 140
seasonal workers not one of them is
British he struggles to find enough
local workers in rural Scotland the
future worries him we've built up an
industry entirely based on people coming
from the EU and without them well it
would be very very difficult I mean I I
don't I don't know how we would even
begin to do our work the nearby town of
our growth has seen better days hardly
anyone here can make a living from
fishing anymore
[Music]
many shops on the high street are vacant
they lack customers with money to spend
it's somewhat busier at the barber shop
though employees as well as customers
are from Eastern Europe migrants from
the EU are needed everywhere they say
the only departments the fish factory
here that is chicken factories around
here then fish factories is not really
easy job as well and also we all know
fish smells you know it's not easy Joe
some regional politicians have a
different view though brexit supporters
would rather send unemployed Scots to
work in the fields when I was a boy I
worked on the farms when I was at school
during the holidays and we went out in
money doing that and with the foreign
people coming across the the guest the
gaff start bite they're coming across
this is actually made that the you know
the local people perhaps don't have the
opportunity locals however wouldn't want
to live in these containers on the farm
and be woken at 5 a.m. to start picking
says Dimitri alongside other seasonal
workers Dimitri earns the minimum wage
for 10 to 12 hours a day
we had some Scottish guys yeah that they
came they work two three days and they
left because of the hard job
dimitri would like to stay in scotland
permanently instead of just during the
harvest season and he'd like to see more
of scotland than just the strawberry
fields his dream is to visit the
scottish highlands someday but brexit
could stop that ever happening
you